for too
long this has gone on
how much more are we gonna accept this
[ __ ]
it comes a time where you just put your
foot down
and you say no more
no i'm not talking about my beard jesus
christ i'm talking about
shitty tumblr blocks
i reviewed them in the last episode
brides throwing cats
sport balls replaced with cats so today
it's all about to change we're gonna
create
not just one but five new blocks
that's gonna blow all these three
out of the park
blog idea number one
people becoming nigel thornberry
let's start with the me
let's start with me i think i can say
some [ __ ] sentence normally
let's make that nose pop that's
it
there's a secret behind how he got his
front teeth so large
but we leave that mystery for another
time
all right eyebrows more like no brows
yeah bye
that that looks good 10 out of 10. oh
man
yes that looks so good so that's uh
that's just one
we could go into other youtubers uh make
a whole [ __ ] video about it i'm sure
let's do one more okay let me tweet
tweet out actually
if you could see one youtuber
as nigel thornberry you pick
and why oh look three seconds and
one said dan or phil i am so surprised
by this
wow you bros are really original with
your creative thinking
all right everyone's saying
jacksepticeye oh you know what that i
got the perfect picture
all right let's i'll i'll just do this
one quick all right
they kind of look the same already
let me just be the first to say
jesus [ __ ] christ they look identical
how could we be this blind jacksepticeye
nigel thornberry confirmed
anyway let's move on with more blogs so
another great idea that i had was to
replace
phones would get this oh wait actually i
want to do something
so another idea of a blog that i had
which is quite genius let's get this
phones
replaced with bananas
here we have a man yelling at a phone
but wouldn't it be funnier if he yells
at a banana
hilarious yeah
that was worth five minutes
oh it's not a phone it's a banana
let's do another one photoshop the idea
number three
families with their faces replaced with
the baby
boom hilarious look how funny that is
look at this family
beautiful that baby's a [ __ ] pimp
the [ __ ] is that baby wearing actually
what the [ __ ] is that
grandma's old beard jesus all right we
have time for
for another one this one is called fake
photoshop fails so there's a lot of like
awkward photoshops where people try and
look more muscular look at this
look at this douche so basically we're
gonna take someone who
has not photoshopped failed and we're
gonna add in a photoshop fail
so that people will think they're a
total loser
let's do jacksepticeye because he's
becoming a meme on this channel
oh perfect now we add in this bicep
thing
it actually matches pretty well god damn
it jack look at that
what a photoshop fail what a total loser
all right who else did we get just need
someone that showed up
yes yes
phil i am sorry for what's about to
happen to you
wow phil thinks that looked real
he thought it would fool us
so lame oh my god so embarrassing
now the final vlog i asked you bros for
help it's basically gonna be
nicholas cage replaced with steering
wheels i know
steering wheel as ghost rider i don't
think you bros understood what i
asked for i asked you to replace
oh wait did i say wrong
oh i said
nicholas cage replaced with steering
wheels
we but it should have been steering
wheels replaced with nicolas cage
oh oops oopsie
well i'm gonna leave it at that so thank
you bro so much for watching
leave a like if you enjoyed and if you
want to see more
i guess watch some more videos see you
bros in the next video
as always stay awesome that is a lot of
chins for a baby